So this is the Bellman equation that
we were just talking about, right?
So the value of a state is the max over
all the actions, the reward that you get
for taking that action on this
state plus the discounted value
of the state you end up in weighted by
the probability that you end up there.
So this should look familiar, right?
>> No, it doesn't look familiar at all.
I mean, there's a V,
there's a max on the outside,
there are more parenthesis,
it's a reward of SA instead of, what?
You're making this up.
>> So, first of all, parenthesis
shouldn't be an issue, right?
Parenthesis just let you group things,
but yeah,
I think you did actually explain this
a different way in the other lecture.
So, I use v for
value instead of u for utility.
>> Okay.
>> And, I think of rewards as being
issued as a function of taking
a state in an action so
taking an action in a state.
Which is to say that you're
in some state of the MVP.
So in particular if we're in some
state S and we take some action A,
we get some reward for having done that
R(SA) and then we land in some new state
S prime I guess that is different then
how you were talking about it before.
>> Yeah when we went over the definition
of an MVP I did point out that you could
think of reward as a function of state,
or as a function of state in action, or
as a function of state action and
next state.
And, they were kind of all
mathematically equivalent,
so this is what we're going to be
doing for the rest of this class.
We're going to be talking
about it this way?
>> Yeah, I'm used to thinking about v as
being the value function, so I think I'm
going to slip into it no matter what,
we might as well just switch to it.
>> Okay, so we're going to do V's,
we're gong to do R S of A's, but
everything that we learned before in our
Scooby Doo flashback still holds now.
>> Yeah, yeah.
It's notational difference and otherwise
it really leads you to the same stuff.
>> Okay we shall see.
>> So what the Bellman Equation is
supposed to represent is the sequence of
rewards received by an agent that's
hopping around in the world.
It starts off in state
S1 it takes action A1,
it gets reward R(s1,a1) for that.
Then it lands in state s2 and
from there it takes action a2 and
receives reward R(s2,a2) and
ends up in s3 and this whole process
just continues ad infinitum.
>> Okay, so you're seeing a bunch of
s a r, s a r, s a r, s a r, s a r's.
>> Exactly, right.
You can think of history as just
being SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR.
>> Oh, so
it's like a pirate with a reverse lisp.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I guess that's
one way to think about it.
So when we talk about the value of this
sequence, it's almost as if what we're
talking about is the value given
that we start off in some state S.
And we notice that eventually, that
we're going to get to some new state S,
and, that value can also be
represented by this value function, so
that's what gives us this recursive
form, that the value of the next state
can be plugged in to represent
the infinite rest of the sequence.
>> Sure, that's sort of the whole point.
Okay, I'll buy that.
>> Cool, all right, so we're going to
now, try to mess this up a little bit,
by thinking about infinity
a slightly different way.
>> As bigger or smaller?
>> Just starting it
in a different place.